all right guys I went to Whole Foods
yesterday
and I got this dress and I can't decide
if I like it or not it's a little big
but I kind of like flowy
um and it's funny I always make fun of
like the oh
I always make fun of the Trad wives and
I'm like this is kind of like a farmer
outfit but whatever
um Okay so
I was thinking about
how we often slip up as people right and
we have all these phrases in language
that sort of slip up how we really feel
so I was thinking about
how an insult to man
is that he acts like a woman
think about that why would it be
insulting
for a man to act like a woman
but it's uh
compliment if a woman dominates a man's
world
isn't that interesting
I'm not interesting so it's like
we almost have all these slip UPS where
we know
that men are superior because again I
really the more I think the more I'm
like gosh the natural world world order
has to be
men women children
maybe government I haven't decided to
think more about that one but
maybe like a god-centered government
maybe has to go above men because you
have to submit like to Authority imagine
for like peace and whatever like if in
the Army you have to submit you can't
you know the police you have to submit
so maybe it's Government after God
but I was thinking about how really
we know deep down that men are smarter
because men that act like women are not
regarded as smart
they're not regarded as honorable and if
anything you'll hear trade cons
on the men that act like women
and everybody
you should I don't know
but my more point is how I wonder if
this
how language really does
tell us how we really feel about things
and it's interesting
because in this scenario
we do see
how we really feel
about men acting like women and the
funny thing is people think I hate women
but I just like to live in reality
and men's beings or at least The Men We
reproduce with must be superior because
they create everything important you
know I started looking into
Madame Curry or whatever Curry chick
um that everyone regards it's like this
woman entrepreneur and it turns out her
husband
worked with her
and after he died she had like no
breakthroughs that's what I'm hearing
um no correct me if I'm wrong but it
seems to be like the same trope
women assist men and when they want to
get more attention like when the
they want to like
make a propaganda campaign out of it
they basically say that the women
invented stuff and I don't really know
if we're meant for inventing maybe
researching or like
I mean I'm sure there's stuff that we've
invented but you guys see what I mean
like just naturally we don't do it as
much
and it's not a hate on women it just
we're better when we follow orders from
Men
does that mean we're idiots
yes compared to men
and it sounds super crazy
when you say it out loud and people
think I'm sexist
but I've honestly just been seeking like
the truth about the world for years I'm
just a curious person
and the more I think
I know that everyone thinks I don't
think but the more I really just think
about what works and what doesn't work
it seems like female-led societies don't
work it seems like female-led companies
don't work
it seems like females don't really
invent a lot and when they do invent a
lot they're usually just taking credit
for the men's stuff
um
you know uh none of this
all the women that are like these great
women inventors or whatever just don't
seem
real
and it seems like most of the time when
the women are doing this
some man around her was like I can make
way more money if she's in charge of
stuff
she's the face of it
and they realize that beauty is currency
beauty is attention and therefore we can
get more done
with the women now there's been female
philosophers
there's been females that have made
impacts in society I'm not saying they
haven't but
it's just interesting because it doesn't
seem like we really do much if we don't
follow the natural order of the world
and we're left to our own devices so
maybe I'm just a sexist
are my eyebrows good guys I do not
understand like makeup but I'm getting
better I'm Better Than I Used to Be but
maybe I'm crazy maybe I'm just sexist
but
this is just when I look at the world
this is what I see so
I don't know guys
and and I realized they the academics
won't tell us
when
um stats make women look bad like I said
the one out of 25 women
do cam work and Twitter corrected it
without even asking me where I got my
numbers from
and the funny thing was if I included
strippers
prostitutes and women that accept sex
from Instagram
the number would be higher not lower but
the academic institutions know that they
can't
um report on a lot of this stuff
otherwise a lot of them will lose their
life's work is what I'm hearing and then
like the the Liberals will say Source
that's a one-off but then when you think
more through it you're like I heard it
from this person this person this person
there has to be some truth here it's not
just Fringe cases
and that's the problem is the Liberals
made these institutions so they could
give us these made up like fake sources
and you know it's hard because
conservatives will be like facts don't
care about your feelings but really
nobody needs real facts
we just need to look at the world
and what we really see do we see like
and even I was thinking about this
women take off their clothes before men
want sex because we look around and the
women are already taking off their
clothes a lot quicker before men are
asking them for sex
You could argue maybe corn
switches it
but in person the women are getting
naked way before the matter asking them
to get naked so maybe we've been lied to
about sexuality
because what do I see I see women
dressing provocatively way more than men
are asking them to
they want you not to believe what's in
front of your eyes and I'm not blind and
they will not make me blind so I don't
know I've just been thinking a lot let
me know what you guys think
in the comments like the video bye